denise manuel labor jobs here in the
valley really proven difficult to fill a
local technical school says there's a
high demand in certain fields but few
people are applying madison kimbrough
joining us live from their henderson
campus location with the very latest
whether it be hvac technicians
electricians or plumbers here at nti
they say the need is so great that they
have contractors reaching out daily for
qualified workers
it's so hot out here there's always
going to be a demand for hvac and
especially with electricians plumbing
nineteen-year-old caleb furch just
landed his first job as a service
technician after finishing a three-month
program at the national technical
institute and while he knows the demand
is high for workers in this field he
feels like people his age just don't
want to put in the work to make it a
profession i think that as a generation
it's just
a lot of us are a little bit on the
lazier side seems like a lot of people
now are just really can i work from home
can i make the most money as possible
short term the opportunities for growth
within the electrical hvac and plumbing
industry is at an all-time high michael
barnes a senior technician with air
supply air conditioning and heating says
it's all about quality over quantity but
come the spring and summer months they
need all the help they can get
april may june
it's right around the corner and we'll
definitely have to amp up and while the
number of applicants could be higher as
of now derrick neismith with nti says
that at one point during the peak of the
pandemic their attendance grew by about
200 percent we had individuals from all
walks of life that never would have
caught you know thought to be plumbers
electricians or hvac technicians
re-evaluate their lives and
they knew they had to make a change
now those interested in nti's program
will have a link attached to this story
up on our website on how to get started
as they have classes morning day and
night reporting live in henderson
madison kimbrough live local now